hi I'm Rachel and I'm a student at
Columbia but we see if theoretically a
human were able to travel at the speed
of light um my teacher told me somewhat
confusingly that we might see the the
past in the present or may have been the
past in the future I can't really
remember simultaneously but whatever his
response was it didn't really make a lot
of sense to me so I was wondering if you
could give me a better clarification
Rachel this is a great question so about
what happens when you go to the speed of
light I mean this is a great we love to
ask this question in physics class it's
big fun here on big thing but if you
have mass which we all do
we are not pure energy we are not beams
of light we're not electrical fields
we're not gravitational fields we have
mass it has been shown beyond any doubt
that you cannot go the speed of light
you can go arbitrarily fast approaching
the speed of light but you can't quite
go the speed of light all the energy you
pump in just adds to your mass and this
seems incredible it adds to your mass
relative to something you're going to
run into in a particle accelerator where
an atom smasher like at CERN in
Switzerland we call it a target that you
run into that said you can't help but
wonder what would happen if you go the
speed of light you got to figure the
only light you'd see is the light come
that you'd run into either light that
you happen to cross paths with or light
that was beamed straight at you you
wouldn't see anything else about the
change in time there's been a lot of
talk about that can time have a speed
effectively the can you go backwards in
time apparently not people live to
speculate but they can't get enough what
about this what happens if you fall into
a wormhole and then you like end up at
another part of the universe like at
another time maybe but if you try to
fall into a gravitational thing of that
strength a black hole for example which
is a star with so much gravity light
doesn't escape it would kill you you'd
be sin gravity between your feet and
your head would be so that just the
difference in gravity would be so high
it would stretch you
into a piece of spaghetti which would
also make you dead but you can't help
but wonder that's a great question my
second question is um are there any
reasons besides ethical dilemmas that we
haven't shot some of our trash from
earth into space and I know it might
contribute to space junk but if we shot
it far enough away um besides maybe then
contributing to other creatures
environments if they do exist what are
the downsides to doing that and why
haven't we if it might then clear up um
space on earth and clear some of the
pollution that we have we're not
contribute than to landfills we might be
able to shoot it elsewhere why we don't
throw trash into space because it's too
expensive lifting a ton of material into
space takes an extraordinary amount of
rocket fuel and by the way when people
want to send this much plutonium-238
which is not even the weapons plutonium
a baseball saw a grapefruit-sized people
freaked out because the rockets
sometimes blow up now one thing I really
want your generation to embrace is that
the earth is a closed system we cannot
leave the earth there's no place to go
there's no place to throw your trash and
I wouldn't be surprised if maybe not you
but your kids develop ways to mine our
landfills we throw away so much valuable
stuff right now especially raw materials
I may be wrong of course always may be
wrong but I wouldn't be surprised if
that turns out to be economically
reasonable all this plastic that's
really hard to create and hard to get to
break down it has value you know like I
have some clothing made out of old water
bottles right so just let go of the idea
of throwing stuff off the earth it's
just too easy a solution what we need to
do is not throw stuff away but you've
heard it you've heard of the hundred
times reduce what we need to throw away
recycle the stuff that we create and
reuse it reduce reuse
those are the things we want to do and
then I did a video years ago there's a
fourth one rethink yes rethink big think
reduce reuse recycle all good the key to
the future Rachael is not to do less
that's not what we're talking about in
my engineering my engineering colleagues
in me and I we are talking about doing
more with less more efficient
transportation more efficient use of
fuel more efficient use of farmland more
efficient everything then that way we'll
have to throw away less and we can dare
I say it change the world great
questions Rachel